this is tomorrow same standing in for
reviewer Richard weakling journey to the
savage planet is a fantastic name for a
pulpy sci-fi game but it's a bit of a
misdirect when taken at face value sure
there are things that want to kill you
in journey to the savage planet but
they're only a minor inconvenience
rather than the main focus instead the
emphasis here is on exploration coupling
this with genuine humour and a charming
tone to present a light-hearted and
singularly focused chunk of sci-fi
adventuring
[Music]
the entire game takes place on a single
planet located deep in uncharted space
you're strapped into the space boots of
an employee of kindred aerospace a
rinky-dink outfit that's proud of its
standing as the fourth best interstellar
exploration company you have to catalog
the flora fauna and life located across
the various biomes of planet ary 26 to
determine if it's fit for human
habitation
what would the whole climate change
ruining earth thing journey to the
savage planet excels when it comes to
the assortment of tools and equipment
you can gradually craft and use to reach
every nook and cranny of the planet
surface you're immediately free to
explore as you see fit but it doesn't
take long to discover plenty of
inaccessible areas as such much of the
game is spent scanning the flora and
fauna to reveal whether they have
gameplay benefits or are just there to
contribute to the planets aesthetic some
plants may contain seeds that restore
your health or produce project our
explosives while alien critters are
filled with resources you can gather if
you're heartless enough to put a laser
blast between their eyes gathering these
resources and locating items that can be
reverse engineered using your ships 3d
printer allows you to craft equipment
like grappling hooks
double jump upgrades for your jet pack
and other tools that make traversal and
deeper exploration possible each new
upgrade opens up more of the planet for
you to probe by the end of the 10-hour
adventure you'll be gliding across
natural zip lines hundreds of feet in
the air
propelling across perilous chasms with a
triple jump and using a powerful ground
pound to unearth new passages journey to
the savage planet adopts the
metroidvania formula and executes it
wonderfully presenting you with an ever
growing arsenal of tools that are
satisfying to use and feed into the
game's inherent focus on exploration of
course the other side of this equation
is the planet itself which is well worth
turning inside out ary 26 is split into
three distinct biomes each one is
moderately sized resulting in the
planets scale feeling manageable and
allowing you to explore freely without
the fear of getting lost when presented
with multiple paths it's easy to choose
one over the other because you know
getting back to that initial fork in the
road is going to be relatively easy this
encourages you to poke your nose in
every crevice travel to every faraway
cave and check behind every
waterfall you're often rewarded for
doing so with extra resources or
important upgrade items hidden
throughout the planet not to mention the
visual trees are on offer in each
disparate biome journey to the savage
planet isn't a completely leisurely tour
though your first order of business is
to develop a futuristic blaster pistol
but combat is a means to an end rather
than a major part of the game and ends
up being a drag defeating any aggressive
predators involves a rinse and repeat
pattern whereby you use a nifty sidestep
or a jump to avoid an attack before
following up by shooting one or multiple
weak points there are only slight
deviations on this back and forth that
require you to lob an explosive or
poison cloud at the enemy before you can
pepper its weak points
the pistol never feels quite accurate
enough for the job especially because
you're usually being asked to hit small
targets and each of the combats faults
come to a head during the game's closing
moments as you're thrown into one fight
after another before facing off against
the final boss you can play the whole
game cooperatively with a friend but
Corp doesn't alter the moment-to-moment
gameplay in any significant way
conflicts are easier with two people
sure but there's nothing about the co-op
experience that's intrinsically built
for more than a single player you can
explore the planet together or Optus
split up and cover different ground but
that's about it playing with a friend
can result in moments of emergent humor
but journey to the savage planet is also
genuinely funny thanks to an abundance
of FMVs located on your ship these show
an incredibly eccentric videos mock and
parody everything from exploitative
corporate practices to the video game
industry the humor is somewhat
front-loaded but this does help the
games irreverent charm establish itself
earlier neater savage planet borrows
plenty of familiar elements from other
games yeah it does so in a carefree way
that sets it apart from other sci-fi
exploration games settling on a relaxing
play style that's informed by its single
vivid planet and tightly focused design
it only takes a couple of hours to
reveal its humdrum combat but this is
the only significant damper on what is
an entertaining slice of light-hearted
planetary exploration
[Music]
you